foreign
tology
I know what you're all thinking
Jurassic Park
maybe Ross from Friends
perhaps even Indiana Jones but that's
archeology
let me show you some real paleontology
now first of all let's take a step back
in time not quite to the Jurassic at
least not yet but to January 21st 2021
when I received a email about curious
discovery made in Rutland in the
Midlands
as a paleontologist you can probably
imagine I get countless messages and
emails from people saying oh we've made
a cool fossil discovery
being completely honest
most of the time
it turns out to be well a weird-shaped
Rock
but
little did I know this email would
change my life
the fine to be made at Rutland water
Nature Reserve
by Joe Davis who works for the
leicestershire and Rutland Wildlife
trust to run the reserve in partnership
with angling water who own the land
whilst doing some routine maintenance in
one of the reserved lagoons
he'd lowered the water levels and Joe
had spotted by chuns this structure
unsure of what to make of it he thought
um
could this be a bit of old pipe Maybe
or perhaps
is this a dinosaur skeleton he joked
luckily
Joe thought to himself well
is this could it be an important
Discovery so crucially he sought expert
advice
when these photos pinged into my inbox
I immediately recognized them
as large vertebrae
from the spine of an ichthyosaur
or is colloquially known as a sea dragon
now I do need to clear that name up just
a little bit
because I'm sorry to say they're not
dragons sorry they're also not swimming
dinosaurs
they're not the Loch Ness Monster on
tour either
and they're most definitely not as the
BBC's of them Sea Dragon dinosaur
dolphin fossils
terrible
ichthyosaurs are in fact
an awesome group of ancient marine
reptiles that lived in the prehistoric
Seas as dinosaurs reigned Supreme on
land
like modern day whales and dolphins they
gave birth to live young and they
breathed there
unfortunately ichthyosaurs went extinct
around 90 million years ago our Rutland
dictionar lived during the early
Jurassic around about 180 million years
ago
this is a time when Rutland was deep
underwater covered by an ancient
tropical sea
now I spent
most of my professional career of around
14 years studying thousands of
ichthyosaurs
and this has been a great pleasure to
travel around the world study lots and
lots of ichthyosaurs and so when I
received these photos I immediately knew
that this could be something very
special indeed but of course just
looking at photos it's hard to know
exactly whether this is going to be
something unique or is it just a few
vertebrae
speaking to fellow Marine reptile expert
Dr Mark Evans who has also sent details
of the find we decided to visit the site
in February and lead a and I'll add a
mini excavation a bit of an exploratory
dig to see what we could uncover
on a cold day in February where the
ground was literally Frozen right
beneath our feet
spend so much time meticulously removing
the Jurassic clay from around the
skeleton
we were blown away because we revealed
what appeared to be a gigantic skeleton
unlike anything ever found in Britain
before
clearly this was a big deal
or we have to be very quick to contain
our excitement because due to the damp
wintry conditions and the fact that this
was a super fragile skeleton it meant it
wasn't the right time to collect this
atheosaur so unfortunately it might seem
a little bit counterintuitive but we had
to re-berry the ichthyosaur and we had
to cover it with plastic sheets and then
Jurassic clay because you have to
remember this of course is an active
nature reserve and so they had to also
the Nature Reserve they had to raise the
water levels to then the eclipse went
back under the water but it was actually
protected and then waiting for what felt
like millions of years
in six months we were back on site but
this time with a superb team of
paleontologists
whilst we when we arrived on site we had
to pick up where we left off and so we
removed that those plastic sheets remove
the Jurassic clay and start to expose
some more of the skeleton
we're overly ambitious in February
we thought based on that little dig that
we did the one day excavation we thought
okay we could probably get the entire
skeleton out of the ground in just one
week yeah we were wrong the skeleton was
much larger more important and more
complete than any of us would have
imagined and it doubled our time on site
we spent 14 and a half days all together
spread over three weeks and this was
also working very long hours from
sunrise to sunset
whilst the team was Excavating the
ichthyosaur we also had to look out for
all sorts of other pieces in the
surrounding Matrix of the of the
ichthyosaur so in my hand here I'm
actually holding one of the isolated
teeth from this ichthyosaur we also
found hundreds of these squid-like
ammonites we found lots of fossil shells
and these are all really important
because they help to build up this
bigger pitch of the ancient Jurassic
ecosystem in which this ichthyosaur
lived
the team also had to move fast as well
this really was quite a Race Against
Time because once we exposed the
skeleton there was more chance that it
could end up degrading further so team
members like Dr Emma Nichols here had to
apply a consolidant of thin glue that
seeps into the bones and helps them to
become more robust to remove the
skeleton out of the ground
once we've fully exposed the skeleton we
then could eventually record all of our
measurements and get a full data set
for example like for the school
Nigel here who I co-led the excavation
with so Nigel focused on the
conservation side of things ensuring
that the ichthy store remains safe and
secure throughout the entire excavation
Nigel is holding
an ichthyosaur a regular-sized
ichthyosaurus skull look at the size
comparison to this Jurassic giant that
we're Excavating pretty phenomenal and
this ichthyosaurus should say that
Nigel's holding this is actually of a of
a species I named after him a few years
ago called ichthyosaurus larkini
whilst on site one of the team members
Steve Day created a wonderful
photogrammetry model which
photogrammetry is an interesting
technique where you take thousands of
photos and put them together and build a
three-dimensional model
now what you're looking at first of all
here is that is a base model that we
made back in February but watch this
little video as we begin to zoom in you
can see some of the spine that we
exposed in February
it's pretty cool it's three-dimensional
but now watch you can superimpose the
entire skeleton that we'd revealed in in
the summer
is the main excavation now we can zoom
in it can you can look at all of the
finer details of the bones in the
three-dimensionality of them and like
magic now we remove the Jurassic clay
now we zoom out and are able to see just
how complete this ichthyosaur is so you
start from the very tip of the style all
the way down to the penny size vertebrae
pretty cool and we're even able
to pick out individual bones and look at
them in three dimensions like this this
is the sort of techniques that are sort
of revolutionizing paleontology we're
able to capture all of this data whilst
the ichthyosaurus sat in the ground so
before we've even removed anything now
we've taken that out of the ground we
still have this data and we can send
that to our colleagues all around the
world
of course now fully uncovered
it's me taking a nap
it's time to literally get this Jurassic
giant out of the ground much easier said
than Dawn when you're dealing with such
a complete and very heavy fossil Wing
several tons
the first Port of Call was to create a
trench all the way around the skeleton
and the reason for that is that we
needed to get right on underneath the
skeleton so that we could begin the
process of plaster jacketing so those
white bits you can see in the image
that's not snow although it was very
cold a few few days on the side that's
actually plaster a plaster jacketing is
an important process in the field of
paleontology we use these protective
plaster jackets that essentially care
for and secure the bones and the
surrounding Matrix so that we can take
them out of the field and into the lab
so that we can analyze the fossil and
the Matrix and work out what's going on
we also had to for the bigger
School block and the body block we also
had to create a wooden frame to help
support the immense weight
after various challenges on site
we finally managed to remove the entire
skeleton after dissecting it into
several more manageable blocks but this
one block here which is the main body
block this weighed one and a half tons
it's actually been removed which is
quite nice it's actually been removed by
Joe Davis who found the ichthyosaur
and this was an interesting moment for
the team because it's quite an emotional
moment because we'd spent and invested
so much time and energy into the sixth
theosaur excavation that this moment
captured that final piece where we're
removing this from its final resting
place 180 million years ago
on January 10 2022
this is almost one year after Joe had
made that incredible discovery
angling water and the University of
Manchester issued a joint press release
announcing the find it is Joe and I on
the BBC breakfast Studio chatting about
this discovery and revealing it to the
world
amazingly the story went viral we were
picked up on a multitude of different
platforms TV radio newspaper went viral
all across social media we were thrilled
to bits with this it was amazing amazing
response about our beautiful ichthyosaur
but one of the things is is why do you
think exactly did the sexiest or get so
much interest
first of all
everybody loves a cool fossil especially
when it's big and it's complete so
you've got a massive tick there but
genuinely this ixia saw was an apex
predator at the very top of its food
chain it's in the Jurassic sea so again
another big tick and admittedly the
photograph is very cool although it is
me again laying down
but on top of that one thing it's
important to highlight is the very fact
that Britain is the birthplace of
ichthyosaurs
the sixth theosaurus specimen in the in
the photo this was the first ichthyosaur
specimen brought the attention of
science found by Mary and Joseph Anning
more than 200 years ago in the lion
Regis on the Dorset Coast
nowadays
finding ichthyosaur fossils in the UK
generally they're found on the somerset
the Dorset and the Yorkshire coastlines
and that's because you have the constant
erosion of the foreshore and the cliffs
you might be lucky to find say the
isolated one or two vertebrae on the on
the beach if you go looking but still
finding a complete skeleton and
especially anything large on the
coastline is incredibly rare this is why
I find in the Rutland ichthyosaur in the
center of the UK in an unusual exposure
is so extraordinarily rare
so what next for this significant
specimen
well despite ongoing plans to try to
replace the Rutland water Nature Reserve
with the Joe racic Park
I'm sorry I'm sorry I apologize
compose myself too
no the next major step is for Nigel
to clean and conserve the entire
skeleton and this is going to take at
least two years to get to that point
at that stage then me and the rest of
the team were able to study the XC store
in as much detail as possible and then
prepare it for its eventual display at
Rutland
where it will then attract hopefully
millions of people will travel around
the world to come and see this specimen
Marvel at this Jurassic Giant and
understand the hidden history right
beneath their feet
what an incredible journey
with most fossil fines
there's always an element of luck
involved you know being in the right
place at the right time
people search their entire lives for
something like this and never even come
close
the funny thing is Joe wasn't even
looking for this he genuinely stumbled
upon this exceptional discovery
at 10 meters long the Rutland
ichthyosaur is the most complete
skeleton of a large prehistoric reptile
ever found in the UK
this once in a lifetime Discovery
represents one of the greatest finds in
British paleontological history
on a personal level
leading this excavation and revealing
this Jurassic giant has been one of the
highlights of my career
thank you all very much for letting me
share this journey with you
[Applause]